How much psychology can you put into a manga?
If I were to ask this question to Eiichiro
Oda, the author of One Piece, his answer would
probably be: Everything.
Or at least something along that line.
In fact, I would argue that the psychology
behind Oda´s characters is the single biggest
reason that his story appeals to such a broad
audience up to this day.
And I mean that quite literally; Regardless
of where you´re from or how old you are.
You can enjoy the story as a teenager, looking
at it through innocent and excited eyes.
Enjoying the fights, cheering for the characters,
and feeling the impact of the major emotional
moments of the show.
However, a lot of the major characters in
the story also have their subtleties that
aren´t immediately noticeable without a certain
amount of personal life experience.
Such nuances have been constructed in such
a way that they add a subtle, but impactful
portion of realism and depth that make them
more and more relatable throughout the years.
These characters especially reflect parts
of the human mind and persona that might be
picked up upon only by someone who has had
a similar experience, or have had enough life
experience to consciously, or even unconsciously,
pick up on these subtle underlying themes
of some of these characters.
Psychology is intertwined all throughout One
Piece and can be found distinctly for each
character.
Today, however, I want to explore with you
the thematic mind of one person in particular;
to examine what impact his theme has on the
audience and to demonstrate how psychology
can cleverly be made visible in a medium like
Manga or Anime.
Let´s talk about the purple tiger.
Let´s talk about Marine Admiral Fujitora;
his blind justice and why it makes him the
best developed admiral out of the lot.
Fujitora, or as he is truly called, Isshō,
is a broadly built, middle-aged man that has
been recruited into the ranks of the marines
after the time-skip.
His most prominent features are the deep scars
over his eyes that mark the spots where Isshō
blinded himself with his sword after having
witnessed something truly horrific.
His character design is dominated by his samurai-like
appearance, that have made it easy to speculate
that he has some connection to Wano.
Same as the other admirals, Fujitora´s character
has been based on a Japanese actor.
In Fujitora´s case, this is Shintaro Katsu
or more specifically on his role as Zatoichi,
the blind swordsman.
Both characters share a number of distinct
similarities: Both carry a shikomizue, a cane
sword that they use for both walking and fighting.
Both share a love for gambling, a theme that
is especially pronounced with Isshō, who
not only likes to gamble literally but he
also likes to roll the dice when it comes
to fights and important decisions.
He literally does so, when torn between duty
and moral, having to decide whether or not
to assist Doflamingo against the Straw Hats.
We can also see this in his standoff with
Law and Doflamingo, where he brings down a
meteor without certainty who or what it would
hit.
Also, both Isshō and Zatoichi share a strong
sense of compassion, putting the interest
of the people before their own.
They both try to help the people out of their
misery as best as they can.
In that sense, both of them are also extremely
humble, not taking a lot of pride in themselves.
Especially compared to some of his colleagues,
Fujitora certainly does not see himself as
superior or as a force of authority to others.
Notably, while he has enjoyed more screen
time than most of the other admirals in the
story, there is not much we know about Isshō´s
past.
We DO know that he was born somewhere on the
Grand Line - possibly Wano - and that at some
point in his life, he decided to blind himself
after being overwhelmed by the cruelty of
the world.
A possibility in this regard is that this
event had something to do with Wano and the
horrific execution of Oden by Orochi and Kaido.
Should he actually be from Wano, there would
certainly have been enough reasons to explain
his painful past.
However, whatever the trigger for this tragic
decision might have been, we can be sure that
Fujitora has suffered through a lot in his
life.
It is a pain literally made visible to the
audience through the scars on his face.
They serve as a constant reminder of his suffering
and hardship and the trauma it must have left
in his heart.
Despite being a Marine Admiral and, in that
sense, an antagonist to Luffy and the straw
hats, it becomes clear very fast that Isshō
is not meant to be an enemy to the crew.
Right from his introduction, Oda makes it
clear that here we are dealing with a very
kind and emotional man, who does not realize
he is being cheated on by Doflamingo´s men
during their gambling.
His kind heart and the respect he shows towards
our protagonists makes it very easy for us
as the audience to empathize with him.
When he stops Zoro from attacking Doflamingo,
he literally apologizes for his behavior after
having been helped by the crew earlier in
the casino.
In general, every major confrontation Fujitora
has over the course of the Dressrosa arc involves
some sort of moral and emotional dialog with
his opponents.
No matter if it´s sharing his concerns over
Dressrosa with Sabo, stopping Doflamingo from
killing Law, or even his short clash with
Luffy.
At no point do we perceive him as a threat.
Much rather, we see him as someone with good
intentions who is opposing Luffy and Co. based
on his responsibility as a marine.
This however does not mean that Isshō is
not intimidating.
Just the opposite, Oda makes it painfully
clear just how powerful the Admiral is.
His skills as a swordsman as well as his powerful
gravity devil fruit make it very obvious why
Fujitora holds the rank of a Marine Admiral
despite having been drafted into the Marines
merely two years ago.
But as we all know, power alone only seldomly
makes for a fascinating character.
And Fujitora in particular is a wonderful
example of how real human psychology can be
incorporated into a fictional character, creating
a distinct and relatable emotional response
in an audience.
In order to be able to dissect and understand
the true power of Isshō’s personality from
a storytelling perspective, we have to start
with his wound.
However, counterintuitively to the general
perception of Shounen manga, we are not talking
about the scars on his face or any other physical
wound Fujitora has suffered over the course
of his life.
Much rather, these scars serve as a visual
representation of a much deeper, psychological
wound he has been dealt.
This wound has its origin in unseen, horrible
events the samurai had to suffer through in
the past.
No matter what it is that he had to witness,
it must have been so terrible that Isshō
felt no other way to deal with his pain other
than to mutilate himself to escape from the
cruelty of the world.
Grounded in this emotional wound is the fundamental
weakness, that Oda has chosen for his intricate
character.
The weakness of a character can be defined
as a lie about the world, a perceived false
truth, if you will, that they wrongfully believe
in and thus have to learn to overcome.
For Fujitora, this weakness seems to be the
belief that piracy is an evil; that has to
be destroyed in order to bring lasting peace
to the world.
This suggests to us, that his past experiences
most likely involved the deeds of pirates
in one way or another.
This weakness subsequently reveals to us the
psychological need of the character that determines
his character development.
In other words, the need is the solution to
the characters weakness that he has to acquire
through his action.
In Fujitora´s case, this clearly is the need
to create a more nuanced world view and letting
go of his hatred for pirates in general.
However, to turn the journey towards this
answer into a threat of story that yields
true moral insights and experiences for both
the character and the reader alike, the psychological
need is usually unknown to the character itself.
Thus, at the beginning of the Dressrosa arc,
Isshō appears to have a very clear imagine
of what is good and what is bad in this world.
To mask his emotional wound and avoid dealing
with it, he hides it behind a mask.
We can see this in all of the fights and confrontations
that he has, where he lets go of his kind
and gentle nature and takes on a hard and
determined stance.
As a result, we, the audience, struggle with
him as he struggles between the ideals of
the world government, the revolutionaries,
Doflamingo and the Straw hats.
His desire after all, is to save and protect
the people of Dressrosa.
In that sense, the entire Dressrosa arc serves
as an overarching representation of what determines
good and evil.
And Fujitora, who has to figure out who stands
for what on this island, serves as a sort
of personification of this struggle.
At the same time, this makes the Dressrosa
story arc his central character development
arc.
To put it into the broader context of the
other admirals, the change he undergoes is
basically from Akainu to Aokiji, roughly speaking.
To explain this analogy, let us take one step
back.
The first step in Isshō’s character development
happens before we ever get to meet him.
Joining the Marines to fight the evil that
has caused him so much pain already is a major
step for him.
It suggests that, despite literally blinding
himself to not see any more of it, he at some
point has decided to face evil again.
How he reached that resolve and determination,
we do not know yet.
However, it also shows us that Fujitora believed
the Marines to be a force of good, standing
off against the pirates.
Thus, Fujitora´s worldview at the beginning
of the arc comes very close to what we know
of Akainu – ideologically, at least.
However, this black and white view is very
quickly challenged by the actions taken by
the straw hats and Doflamingo, who is affiliated
with the government.
As the events progress, we can see Isshō
struggle more and more with his belief until
he finally lets Luffy go.
He breaks through his thought mask, by admitting
to himself that Luffy is actually a kind person.
When we reach the end of the arc, we have
reached an approach that comes much closer
to Aokiji´s where Fujitora acts based on
his morality rather than his duty.
He learns to judge people based on their actions,
rather than their flag.
Thus, he allows Luffy to escape, while taking
it on himself to abolish the system of the
warlords that has caused so much suffering
to the world.
What then is Fujitora´s ideal of blind justice?
To unearth that question, we once again have
to return to the fundamental theme of the
admirals: Is everything we call evil, actually
evil?
Every one of the admirals has their own answer
to this question.
And for Fujitora, I would argue that his sense
of Justice is very closely connected to his
character arc, that we have just discussed.
The first thought, when thinking about blind
justice, at least for me, is the image of
lady justice.
Often depicted as wearing a blindfold, she
represents impartiality.
In other words, the ideal that justice should
be applied without regard to wealth, power,
or other status.
This description hits really close to home
when we think about Isshō’s actions and
ideals.
This of course is further supported by the
fact that Fujitora is literally blind.
He physically cannot discriminate against
people based on their appearance.
As we can witness over the course of the story,
Fujitora decides to serve justice according
to people's deeds and not their affiliation.
Thus, he increasingly conflicts with the world
government´s ideal of absolute justice.
To give you a better idea of this approach
to justice, let´s look at two impactful moments
for his character.
The first takes place after his standoff with
Doflamingo and Law.
After Law is taken out by the warlord, Fujitora
steps in to prevent Doflamingo from taking
Law´s life.
The fair and moral thing to do is to capture
Law, not execute him.
And his job is to serve the justice he deserves,
not any more or less.
He thus protects Law from unjust treatment
by Doflamingo.
The second instance is his confrontation with
Zoro.
Being aware of the kindness the straw hats
showed towards him, he apologizes for standing
in his way and openly verbalizes his internal
struggle that is building up at this point.
What this shows us is that Fujitora is willing
to take responsibility for his actions.
Even if it means going against Akainu and
the Gorosei for letting Luffy go and bowing
to king Riku and thus exposing the world government’s
failure.
It is the just thing to do and Fujitora serves
it just as lady justice does, blindfolded;
in Fujitora’s case, literally blinded by
his own past.
Thus, Isshō’s character truly is psychology
made visible.
His scars literally represent his ideal of
blind justice.
If you enjoyed this video, consider leaving
me a like and some of your thoughts in the
comments below.
Also, if you aren´t subscribed to the channel
yet, I hope I could convince you that it might
be worth doing so.
Welcome on board.
I hope to see you around next time.
Stay curious.
AND.
Until then.
Have a wonderful week.